what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and she-hulk attorney at
law comes out tonight so this is going
to be my review of episodes one through
four spoiler free we're not going to be
going over spoilers in this video so you
don't have to worry about that but there
are some key points that i want to talk
about in this video it is different than
my reaction yesterday we are going into
some details and what i specifically
want to talk about today
is the characters and the actors
how this show is different there is good
and bad
that comes with that we are going to be
talking about good and the bad and i
want to talk about why
i love the post credit scenes of this
show
and something we have to talk about
because everybody is already talking
about it feminism there is some feminism
in the show and we'll get into that in a
bit but first let's start off by talking
about the characters
i think the characters are awesome
i i actually really like tatiana maslany
she
does she did an incredible job as
jennifer walters she hulk and all of the
other characters that are in the show
are really really good they are they're
all really good i like each character i
like the characters that you're supposed
to hate right i like that the actors are
doing such a good job at their roles
that you truly do you're like oh you're
you you suck
you're a scumbag like
they do a really really good job the the
cast is pretty
it's pretty great and
i don't really need to say more than
that because i think once you watch this
show you're going to just watch them and
be like wow everybody did
just a really good job
with their characters and the characters
were actually done pretty dang well i
think you're gonna see that i think
it'll be very apparent after the first
episode now
i will say
this show is different and like i
mentioned that that is good and bad
it's good because it actually is quite
different than a normal mcu show
which is very refreshing
and it's got a lot of comedy to it it's
got a lot of adult humor that's also
kind of safe for kids like i i want to
worry too much about the kids but
the characters in it it's funny to see
them outside of the norm of the mcu like
wonk everybody knows that wong is going
to show up in shihok and he is in more
than one episode and it's funny to see
such a serious character
outside of his normal serious realm
in this you know comedic show that
involves lawyers and lawsuits and things
like that it's really funny to see him
kind of out of his own comfort zone
really so to see characters like that
and other characters as well as kind of
not
themselves i wouldn't say not themselves
but outside of what we truly know them
as and what we've seen them so far in
the mcu is actually really cool it's
really refreshing and it's funny like
it's actually it's actually pretty funny
however
the bad that kind of comes with this
is that the the comedy doesn't always
land
it it doesn't it's kind of like i i know
like thor love and thunder i thought the
movie was hilarious but i know a lot of
people were like it was not it was corny
it was dumb and i think this is gonna be
the same i think this is gonna maybe be
split down the middle of people going
like no that's actually really funny and
then other people going like no it was
really dumb like those jokes weren't
funny um
and that's just kind of
that's just kind of how it is now i will
say the fourth wall breaking it really
works
but is kind of inconsistent like there's
some times where she breaks the fourth
wall and it kind of seems like other
people kind of like hear her break it
and then there's some other times where
she's like having full-on conversations
with the audience
walking next to somebody and they're
completely oblivious so i'm just kind of
like
what are the rules here that was a
little confusing and
the same thing that i just said goes for
the comedy of the wall breaking the
fourth wall breaking uh sometimes it
hits sometimes it misses sometimes it's
really funny
sometimes it's not so funny and that's
just you know
that's just the way it is some are gonna
be funny to people and some aren't and
there are gonna be people who hate this
show and they're gonna be people who
love this show and gonna think
everything's funny and some people are
gonna think nothing is funny at all now
the overall story
uh i will say one thing that i truly
like and one thing that does make this
show different is that each episode kind
of does stand on its own i mentioned
this yesterday that it did seem like
marvel studios finally set out to not
make like a six hour movie
or nine hour movie
and they just aim to make each episode
its own thing and good
and i think they did a really good job
with that um
there were episodes i didn't like and i
do believe
episode 1 maybe episode four was my
favorite um there are some episodes
where i was just kind of sitting there
like kind of like yeah that was like
enjoyable
right it wasn't anything over the top i
wasn't on the edge of my seat i was kind
of just there for the ride um yeah i
mean
i didn't have a bad time with some of
those worse episodes i did truly enjoy
the first episode and i liked i think i
think it was the fourth episode when i
watched it all it was you know in the
theater um at the launch event and they
didn't actually you know tell us like oh
this is episode two this is episode
three starting this is episode four
starting um and i only watched the first
episode at home because i wanted to do
reaction so i actually don't know like
where they stop and start uh but this is
a good point to go into the post credit
scenes so far
there have been scenes that set up other
things in this show but
i think most post credit scenes so far
are just gags
they're just comedy because this is
supposed to be a comedy show um the
first post credit scene i laughed pretty
dang hard um
and the other post credit scenes were
relatively funny i think i thought like
another one was pretty funny and the
other two were just kind of like
but that's just me right that's just my
sense of humor you may love them all you
may hate them all but uh i thought it
was like right in the middle i was like
some were really funny some were okay
now
the part i want to talk about is
feminism because this is a female lead
and there are parts where you know she
it's real i'm just you know it's real
they go into like what it's like to be a
woman in the workplace men talking down
to her like that's real things that
happens in real life sadly and you know
they go into that now the way they go
about it might piss some people off when
i walked out of the screening in the
theater i did overhear some people
talking and a few people that i heard
talking did say like it was a little too
much
um i saw other people say that they
really loved it right and this is men
and women saying this right um so there
were men who loved all this feminist
stuff that was inside of it and there
were women who thought it was too much
actually so i think it's just going to
be on how you feel and i'm really like i
believe in equality and all of that
obviously like that and i'm really just
kind of like that stuff doesn't bug me
right i just believe it's real and it's
out there and they're just addressing it
but for some people out there i know
they're gonna be like this is way too
much this is the mcu blah blah blah blah
you might not like the show i'm just
gonna be completely honest about that
but so far i've truly enjoyed it um
it's not my favorite
i saw a lot of tweets from a lot of like
critics and other people
that are like this is the best mcu show
so far i do not believe that to be true
i still hold loki and one division above
it i probably hold moon knight above it
as well but i do think it's better than
like hawkeye and miss marvel and what if
everybody knows i don't like what
um so overall i had a really good time
watching the first four episodes i think
it's a good show definitely and i only
saw four episodes there are nine
episodes there are a lot more and the
story hasn't really been
brought out too much yet like i said
they like focus on like individual
episodes the overall story
is kind of coming together
but like it's not there yet and i do
believe i heard like five and six are
where it actually kind of starts to
truly come together and uh unfortunately
we have to wait five to six weeks to get
there but you're all gonna watch the
first episode tonight i'll be doing my
watch parties and hopefully you all
enjoyed this episode
and are going to be along for the ride
i'm i'm excited to see where this show
goes i think it does have a lot of
potential and i think of it in strong it
will be some people's favorite mcu show
and it's funny
i enjoy the humor i enjoyed the
lightheartedness of it and i i'm here
for the ride um
hopefully it ends strong i think that
will ultimately determine where i rank
it i don't think there's any way it's
going to beat loki or one division for
me probably not moon knight either but
hey who knows again this is my opinion
please form your own don't just think
something because i said it or somebody
else said it and as always if you like
something and then somebody else doesn't
like it
it's okay it's okay if you don't like
something it's okay if you do like
something don't let other people
and like the pressure of like fitting in
with everybody kind of make you change
your mind just be who you are and if you
enjoyed it don't let people bring you
down and if you didn't i'm sorry
hopefully you like the next one that
marvel and disney plus puts up but hey
i'm excited for everybody to watch it
tonight i'll be doing my watch parties
it'll start at 12 pst actually 11 30 pst
will start before and uh yeah let me
know what you're expecting in the
comments down below don't forget like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on she-hulk and all other mcu
things and as always thanks for stopping
by woof